Elizabeth Holmes ex estrella de silicon
Valley recibió su sentencia casi 20 años
después de fundar terranos una startup
que prometía una Revolución en los
diagnósticos de salud la ex ejecutiva de
38 años Fue condenada a 11 años de
prisión por un juez Federal de distrito
se trata de un caso de fraude en el que
un proyecto impresionante salió adelante
con grandes expectativas solo para verse
luego frustrado por falsedades
tergiversaciones arrogancia y mentiras
aunque se ha declarado inocente la
acusada expresó sus arrepentimientos
estoy devastada por mis fallos Durante
los últimos años he sentido todos los
días un profundo dolor por lo que la
gente Tuvo que pasar por mis errores
Holmes que dice tener fobia a las agujas
fundóteranos a los 19 años con la idea
de fabricar una herramienta que pudiera
extraer una gota de sangre del pulgar y
dar a los pacientes recuentos sanguíneos
completos de forma casi instantánea
pocos años consiguió ganarse la
confianza de los principales
inversionistas convertirse en la primera
mujer multimillonaria de silicon Valley
y en una de las pocas directoras en un
mundo predominantemente masculino pero
en 2015 el escándalo estálló cuando el
medio Wall Street journal reveló que la
máquina prometida nunca funcionó
sunnyvaloani el Antiguo compañero de
Holmes y director de operaciones
deteranos fue juzgado por separado y
también declarado culpable de fraude
está previsto que su condena sea
pronunciada el 7 de diciembre